paolo espino four and four on the season
4.13 era and fp his last time out
against the mets maybe his best start as
a national struck out a career high
seven four games one start against the
phillies this year on one record with an
era of eight he does have a save espino
rocks kicks delivers swinging a high fly
ball to right
soto shaded toward the line moves to his
left sunglasses on makes a one-handed
grabs sagura has fly to right and there
are two out and nobody on now the wine
to the pitch breaking ball swung on a
miss struck him out with a slow curve at
72 miles an hour first strikeout for
speedo it's a one two three start for
paulo espino aaron nola making his 27th
start aaron 28 years old comes in with a
seven and seven record making his 13th
start at nationals park two balls and
two strikes
swinging a miss at a fastball may have
gotten a piece of it but it's a
strikeout nonetheless
they're two outs and ola's pitch
swing at a roll over on the right side
charging in for it is segura he's got it
throws to first bell retired
and so are the nationals no runs no hits
a walk into man left and after one
complete in washington
fills nothing and the nationals
go to the second j.t romuto will lead it
off
swinging a mess at a fastball struck him
out so espino comes back from being
behind 2-0 it's three straight swings
and strikes out rail muto for a second
strikeout
now the pitch swung on hit in the air to
left field coming in is yadiel hernandez
straight in toward the infield makes a
one-handed catch and the side retired
ruiz will be the batter now for the
gnats
and a strike three called on the inside
corner even if it was close raphael
marchand did a great job of bringing it
back
swinging a miss struck him out
and that was a change up that got him
back-to-back strikeouts for nola three
in the game and he works a one-two-three
second we'll go to the third phil's and
the nationals are scoreless
here's raphael marchand no score third
marchand switch hitting catcher at 282
with a homer and a swing and a drive
into left center field that'll get down
for a base hit rafael marchand has the
game's first hit top of the third inning
line drive that's a fair ball going into
right field marchand's on his way to
third o'double stops it first as the
throw goes behind oh duba herrera first
and third with two men down and that's a
six-game hitting streak for herrera so
they're loaded for bryce harper phillies
have hit five grand slams this season
two of them against the nationals ready
for a 1-1 here it is and a swing and a
chopper over the mound behind second
escobar fields it he'll take a side step
to his right and step on the bag for the
out that retires the side no runs couple
of hits and three left two outs bottom
of the third no score leighton thomas
the batter pitch swinging a blast to
left center field herrera back on this
one straightaway center it's over his
head and it's gone
elaine thomas
slices one through the wind for a home
run out of the batters high hill in
straightaway center field his first home
run as a national
his first home run this season and the
nationals take the lead one nothing in
the third inning
this one's well struck to center back is
herrera at the wall a leap and it's gone
wants soto a two-run shot home run
number 23 for juan soto
puts the nationals in front three to
nothing
this one on the putting green where does
this one land
did they hit it oh my goodness
plinko times two nola wines kicks the o2
swinging the ground ball right side
security to his left he's got it he has
to dive to get it but rolling over he'll
throw to first in time
to get josh bell nice play by gene
segura nasty two not top spin on that
one the one two to keyboard
drills through the hole on the left side
two out single here in the fourth for
carter keyboard nice job of staying on
the off speed pitch going down and
barreling up the baseball curveball's
been getting hit a little bit hadn't it
and the pitch
is swung on hitting the ear to left
mccutchen backing up a few steps he's
got it measured he'll reach up and make
the catch and garcia retired on one
pitch no runs on a hit and one man left
by the nationals after four complete
here in washington paolo espino who has
allowed just two hits so far
dotting
in a diamond form 88-89 with his
fastball this one right back at him he
spins out of the way
and s gabar across for out number two
it's so two out nobody on and aaron nola
the pitcher will be the batter the o2
swinging a miss how low is spino five
scoreless against the fills five
scoreless sittings from espino
five strikeouts he threw just eight
pitches
and he's retired the last seven he's
only allowed two hits so here's soto
with the bases loaded walked in the
first homer to dead center last time up
in the third falter delivers soto swings
it's a ground ball pissed the diving rio
multo a base hit into right field espino
has scored rounding third thomas coming
home it's a single to ride and two runs
batted in for juan zoto
he's now driven in four in the game and
the pitch swung on line up the middle
base hit center field
escobar trots home from third to score
it's now the national six and the
phillies nothing the bases again are
loaded here in the fifth
garcia pops it up
[Music]
marchand says he has it so does jt jt
makes the final call
and the inning is finally over three-run
score for the nationals they send nine
men to the plates 32-pitch hitting
between three phillies pitchers will go
to the sixth
fights it off up the third base line
that's going to be a base hit that's a
nine game hitting streak for bryce and
it puts runners at first and second with
one out tim bogar going out to the mound
yeah that's going to be it for espino
well he's gone five and a third
scoreless today that'll load the bases
up for andrew mccutchen
that one's lying down toward left center
field that's going to split the gap and
go into the warning track oh double
scores
all three runs cross the plate harper
and real muto follow suits it's a 6-3
game it's a three-run double for
mccutcheon marchand batting right-handed
against clay here's the pitch
swinging the ground ball right side
moving to his left the second baseman
garcia he scoops and fires and it's in
time to get the out so sam clay
arrives just in time to rescue the
inning got a big league debut here
alberto baldonado 28 year old lefty out
of panama
swinging a miss that is cool first
batter faced in the major leagues for
bel donato after 11 minor league seasons
is a strikeout of matt vearley there's a
souvenir for him that's a lot of bus
rides here's the pitch
fastball swing and a miss at 96 blew him
away alberto baldonado in his big league
debut strikes out a pair lead off double
here in the eighth inning that'll bring
up left fielder andrew mccutchen
back toward the middle of base hit it to
center field real muto muto's around
third he's heading for home he'll score
it'll be an rbi single from mccutcheon
they've trimmed the lead now it's six to
four nationals the bases are loaded they
todd is over seven as a pinch hitter
this year he has six hits and 19 at-bats
and he hits that one sharply and it goes
past garcia off his glove mccutcheon
will score heading home is galvez he's
going to score and the phillies have
come all the way back they've tied it up
at six
amazing ground ball right side garcia's
got it he thought about going home
that's gonna cost him the phillies will
take the lead
it's a 7-6 ball game
well done oh double he'll get a
fielder's choice he'll get an rbi
kennedy trying to pick up his sixth save
for the fills the tying runners at third
but two away here in the ninth inning
fly ball center field herrera is there
under it makes the catch and the ball
game is over the phillies erased a
six-run deficit to win it seven to six
they have swept out the nationals
you